blaise pascal ou encore jean racine sy
sont promenés port royal des champs
ancienne abbaye fondée au xiiie siècle
un lieu historique à visiter à magny les
hameaux pour regarder ça aujourd'hui
c'est avoir un très grand site de 30
hectares dans lequel on peut avoir
d'abord bien sûr le site des ruines de
la les lits de grand jardin avec
l'ancien berger construit par les
messieurs doivent envoyer le xviie
siècle où les jardins que pouvait avoir
le fermier qui ont été reconstituées
c'est un grand parc dans lequel on peut
prendre du temps se promener descendre
par les allées dans une sorte de sous
bois le long de la le long de la vallée
ou suivre une partie de la rivière
lorsqu'on associe de la demie des
vestiges d'une époque qui ont été
gravées sur la toile par de nombreux
artistes un lieu qui raconte son
histoire à travers l'architecturé l'art
au royal c'est aussi un musée national
qui conserve un faire un nombre de
peintures très importante du xviie
siècle la plupart exécuté par un grand
peintre qui est philippe de champaigne
tous ces tableaux ont été peints dans
les années 750 760 pour l'avait mis pour
être mis dans l'église pour être mis
dans les bâtiments et on peut toujours
les voir aujourd'hui de laval et
longueuil ce nom désigne donc les
quelques 1000 jours pour tenter ici pour
dire au vide qu'on avait les bisexuels
port royal des champs un musée national
gratuit jusqu'à 27 ans et qui vous
accueillera lors des journées du
patrimoine les 16 et 17 septembre à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine le
public peut rentrer dans l'oratoire qui
se trouve sur le site de l'abbaye
ce petit oratoire dix neuvième siècle
est fermé depuis 30 ans viennent
habituellement fermés au public
on aura la possibilité de le découvrir
pendant les journées du patrimoine
avant que nous puissions commencer les
travaux de rénovation et de restauration
de ce monument un musée national qui
devrait s'agrandir pour accueillir de
nouvelles voiles et qui se donne un coup
de jeune pour survivre à toutes les
époques